remy is a french oil-painting tradesman
he lives a normal life with his wife
lucille and two children one day while
playing with the kids remy sinks into
the chair he quickly gets up but the
strange occurrence remains on his mind
for a long time starting that day he
experiences similar occurrences
frequently he sinks deep into the couch
and even his own bed before quickly
pulling himself back up because there is
no plausible explanation he assumes it
is all in his head and ignores it one
afternoon remy is in the studio with the
kids he forgets to close the tap which
results in the entire studio being
flooded the simple mistake costs him his
entire fortune and ruins his career
while trying to retrieve the remaining
good paintings he again sinks into the
floor this time he is unable to pull
himself up and ends up in a lake
somewhere in another world apparently
this world has three sons soon a group
of tribesmen notice his presence and run
towards him a terrified remy walks
backward and is pulled back into the
water in the following moment he is back
in his world being dragged out of the
studio by a friend remy knows that what
he saw wasn't just a dream
later at home he tells lucille about his
experience but she dismisses it in an
instant instead she has another thought
occupying her head lucille has fallen in
love with her boss dr geller and wants
to move in with him she feels sorry for
remy but has chosen her happiness over
their marriage losing his wife right
after losing his career is the worst
thing that could have happened to remy
still he tries to be understanding and
talks to her about the relationship to
his surprise lucille has even brought dr
geller to meet him honey this is the man
who's cucking you remy simply allows
them to do whatever they please and
promises to move out in a few days
following that he goes to his family
looking for reassurance they listen to
him but change their attention towards
his cousin soon after a defeated remy
goes to the kitchen to spend some time
alone when he faces another series of
strange occurrences the family cat
freezes mid-air in a jump remy holds it
and spins it around but the cat seems to
have turned into a stuffed toy he even
calls his family to the kitchen before
realizing that the world around him has
stopped the floor becomes loose sinking
remy in once again he screams for help
but before it arrives he is pulled into
the alternate world when he opens his
eyes again he is in the middle of a
forest with the coffee mug still in his
hands he walks down a path and sees a
group of tribesmen slaughtering an
animal as he tries asking them for help
he realizes that they plan to feed him
to their leader remy makes a run for it
while being followed by the tribe in
some time he enters a civilization and
hides inside a cave all of a sudden he
is pulled back into his family house and
the force makes the kitchen a mess his
family hears the noise and finds the
entire kitchen and shambles when they
come up to check remy tries explaining
what happened but they do not believe
him for obvious reasons the shock of
everything makes remy fall unconscious
and he opens his eyes again at the
doctors the visit is not very fruitful
because even the doctor doesn't believe
him the following day remy goes to his
studio where his landlord insurance
agent and clients have gathered to talk
to him about different payments he owes
suddenly they stop talking and moving
abruptly before remy knows it he is
sinking down into the floor yet again he
tries to stop himself but it doesn't
work and he ends up in the alternate
world for the third time he comes out of
a basket on top of a tree as the
tribesmen look at him in appreciation
his appearance seems to be something
everyone was looking forward to as the
crowd erupts into cheers as soon as they
see him they expect him to fly down from
the tree but remy falls to his face
instead the language barrier between him
and the people causes confusion at first
but then he is forcefully made to eat a
green berry which magically makes them
understand each other the leader of the
tribe finally reveals the secret behind
remy's appearance to their world it
turns out that they have been troubled
by a flesh-eating giant named zoten for
a long time he kills and eats anyone he
pleases making the people live in fear
every day the mages of the tribe found a
solution written in ancient books that
said only a man from another world can
save them from the giant beast hence for
the past week they have been performing
rituals to invite the said hero to their
world the reason the strange things were
happening to remy is because he is the
savior of the tribe a shocked remy
claims to be nothing of such sort and
refuses to help them but they hold him
upside down from the edge of a tower to
change his mind he is then taken to an
isolated room where he is supposed to
think of a plan to kill the beast hungry
after an eventful day remy holds a
watermelon and is suddenly teleported
back to his world this time he doesn't
bother telling people about his
experience knowing that no one will
believe him instead he goes to a library
to investigate the situation further the
internet shows no answer to his problems
so he instead resorts to drinking a lot
of protein to gain muscles and fight
zoten in the following scene he is back
in the alternate world with renewed
confidence this is remy's only chance to
prove his worth and he doesn't want to
lose it the tribe gives him a special
sword before asking him for advice on
how to get rid of zotan remy tells them
to move to a new village promising to
protect them on the journey the
villagers are scared bound by a
superstition it says that anyone who
crosses the border will be struck by
lightning remy proves them wrong by
crossing the border first and
encouraging them to do the same this
makes the tribe believe that he is
definitely their savior after walking
for a few hours in search of a new place
they come across two of zoten's men the
duo warns remy to return to the village
but he fights them using his newly
learned but surprisingly good fencing
skills he manages to kill one of the
soldiers while the other flees to his
leader when everything calms down the
people start clearing up the dead body
when asked where they are taking it remy
finds out that they plan to cook and eat
it disturbed by the strange tradition he
orders them to stop immediately and
since the tribe doesn't want to anger
their savior they decide to do as told a
while later a group of people reveals
that zoten is planning an attack on the
tribe and a war is about to take place
when remy is back in the real world he
starts reading books on war tactics and
history he does research about battle
formations governance and many more
things to prepare after finding out that
the most important factor is a motivated
troop remy gives a speech to the tribe
the next time he meets them with a
little encouragement the people are
ready to fight for themselves and their
families one day remy decides to stay
with the tribe and spends the night
surrounded by women they are all ready
to do anything to please him but remy
remembers being cocked and cannot get
harassed their advances make him realize
that he is still deeply in love with
lucille and wouldn't want to be with
anyone else sometime later remy returns
to his home in the original world after
tending to his son he returns to the
tribe only to find himself in the middle
of a battlefield the tribesmen are
losing miserably so he asks them to
retreat to higher ground they do as told
preventing any more loss of lives then
remy decides to put his strategy into
action and goes to a sleeping rival
troop he starts insulting and slapping
them at random urging them to chase him
things work out exactly as he had
imagined and the rival troop is exposed
on an empty battlefield this is when
remy motions his army to attack and
hides inside a tree trunk himself all
those history books taught him the
greatest survival lesson of all being a
coward one third of the enemies are
killed with arrows and the rest are
weakened because of the surprise attack
in a few minutes they retreat in fear
giving the tribe a taste of victory they
bow down to remy who is now their
absolute hero following the war the
tribe has led to a new fertile land
which they declare as their new home
remy becomes the emperor and uses the
knowledge of his world to make the
village a better place soon they make
one progress after another and establish
themselves as a modern civilization remy
is revered as a god and is given many
concubines to sleep with during his stay
in this world he even paints a mona lisa
styled portrait of his favorite mistress
six months pass in a similar fashion and
being the emperor changes remy as a
person earlier he used to be intimidated
by lucille's boyfriend geller but with
the recent change in his behavior geller
is now the one intimidated by remy when
they get into a fight because of their
differences remy is quick to shut him
out it gives him a sense of satisfaction
that the man he once lost to is scared
of him as time passes remy's
achievements turn him into an arrogant
man he treats his people like servants
letting the success get to his head the
people of the village quietly follow his
orders for a few months but start to
revolt as time passes when remy gets a
hint of this he goes to his subjects to
talk about the problem they claim that
they are overworked and paid less just
for the sake of his amusement the
village doesn't need more fancy palaces
instead the emperor must make efforts to
make people's lives better remy tries
negotiating with the rebels but it
doesn't work having had enough they
capture him and kick him out of the
village altogether upon returning to the
real world remy goes to a friend asking
for help to reopen his studio he is now
evidently more humble than he was when
he was an emperor his life gets back on
track as he develops a romantic
relationship with a client named
delphine they start to date but just
when she leans in to kiss him for the
first time remy is pulled back into the
alternate world the tribe has called for
him again asking him to kill zoten to
fulfill the prophecy although remy
doesn't want to get involved he is led
into a cave with the beast a brief fight
later he is about to be killed but just
then he throws a sphere in a random
direction and manages to kill zoten when
the tribe sees the creature dying it
erupts into cheers getting ready for the
final part of the ritual it turns out
that they have to kill and eat remy in
order for the prophecy to be fulfilled
he runs into the woods to save his life
but an old mage destroys an artifact
behind him without the structure remy
won't be able to return to his world he
is soon found and is about to be killed
when suddenly his concubine retrieves
the burning artifact and throws it into
the river as a result he is teleported
back to his family at a hospital lucille
and delphine meet each other upon
finding out that their divorce hasn't
been finalized yet delphine decides to
stay away from remy in the following
scene lucille realizes that she is still
in love with remy and geller was a huge
mistake she tells him that she has
kicked the guy out of her house and is
willing to give their relationship a
second chance in response remy asks her
to always be happy and walks away on her
ass
hell yeah remy back in another world the
people build remy's statue to honor him
as their savior a few months later
lucille and remy are on a beach with
their children oh enjoying their life as
a family the final scene shows remy
watching the tv and finding out that his
painting of the mona lisa has been found
at an archaeological site however
historians think that it was made by a
10 year old da vinci because the
portrait is mediocre
you